[Music]
on this Tuesday night in her own
words I've been through hell an Israeli
woman held captive by Hamas recounts her
ordeal in gaza's tunnels how she was
treated and what her captors told
her the Canadians still stuck in Gaza
plead for help thousands of people are
dying and a Hamas spokesperson speaks
with global news it is not our intention
to
a federal judge approves a long promised
compensation deal for first nation's
families and children what Advocates say
still needs to be
done and he was a very good boy for a
very long
time the extraordinary life of the
world's oldest
dog global national with Donna frez good
evening and thanks for joining us for
the first time the world is hearing what
it's like to be held hostage by Hamas in
Gaza the extraordinary account is coming
from this 85-year-old Israeli woman
released last
night let's go it's okay let's
go you go with this one Shalom she says
as she shook the hand of one of her
captors yev lifshits along with
80-year-old nurit Cooper were held for
17 days they are both safe now but both
their husbands are still in captivity
they and the more than 200 others were
kidnapped when Hamas Fighters stormed
out of Gaza and into Israel on October
7th killing 1400 Israelis and dragging
others back to Gaza today just hours
after her release and with her daughter
by her side lifshitz recounted her
ordeal in what she calls the spider web
of tunnels under Gaza Jeff simple is in
Jerusalem and has our top story
tonight yev lifshitz is one tough
85-year-old
just hours after being released from 17
days in captivity she faced the cameras
a press conference at her hospital and
described her ordeal in Vivid
detail to tell you the truth I've been
through hell that I never imagined
lifshits described how Hamas attacked
her small community forcing her onto a
motorcycle and striking her ribs with a
stick it was very painful I was
struggling to breathe and they took her
underground into this vast network of
tunnels which she likened to a
spiderweb we walked for a few kilometers
the ground was wet and the air was humid
she and four other prisoners were then
separated from the group and from her
83-year-old
husband we were placed in a different
room we had guards and a paramedic
assigned to us a doctor also came to
check on us every 2 or 3 days they slept
on mattresses on the the ground and were
given pita bread cheese and
cucumber they were very kind to us she
says one of her Hamas captors promised
not to harm her because he said they
believe in the
Quran that comment made by a member of
the same group that killed more than
1,400 Israelis including ayelet spitz's
brother she still hasn't received his
body I haven't buried my brother yet so
we haven't had a Shiva yet we haven't
had poer Jewish warning now more than
two weeks on since the attack they are
still working here to identify the
bodies this military base was
frantically set up in the hours after
the attack and its purpose is to
identify bodies that are so badly
damaged that they require expert
forensic identification what I have seen
is beyond um beyond words this doctor
has conducted forensic identifications
for 25 years but has never seen any
anything like this we've seen children
who are
decapitated we've seen children who are
dismembered 800 bodies have been brought
here for identification around 100 are
in such terrible condition they have yet
to be identified leaving many family
members of the missing still unsure
whether their loved ones are dead or
alive Orit mayor is waiting for any news
of her son my life is is not the
same I can't eat I can't
sleep all the time I am am thinking
about about him four families are now
back home together but for more than 200
others the nightmarish wait continues
Jeff simple Global News
Jerusalem as those hostages wait in Gaza
the Israeli government is not listening
to calls for a ceasefire the Army
maintains it will smash Hamas in Gaza
and its bomb bombardment is escalating
Gaza is under almost constant Israeli
fire 400 air strikes today alone the
Israeli Defense Forces say it claims to
have struck a Hamas Command Center and
killed Hamas commanders among the dead
are more civilians the Gaza Health
Ministry run by Hamas says 700 people
have died in the past 24 hours including
at least 300 children Global News cannot
independently verify those numbers what
is certain is that no one can Escape gas
and that includes several hundred
Canadians and their families here are
some of their stories in their own
words my name is say I'm with my brother
Omar right here U me and my parents
actually came from Canada from Bramton
Toronto we were supposed to leave
actually a couple weeks ago but the
plane got delayed and ever since this
war we've been trying to contact Global
Affairs the Canadian embassy and stuff
but so far we have no good news and
right now me and my family are pretty
scared my name is m Hala and I'm 1 years
old I have a family that contains six
people and we stand in lines for bread
like for several hours 45 hours to only
get the minimum amount that we can every
day for water we pay like huge bills
sometimes my name is H and I'm 21 years
old we came last week the this street
would be crowded and the markets are
open but now no more no more uh stores
are open because the supplies are are
nothing are none and uh and there and
plus there's no
electricity uh as you can hear the
sounds of the Ms and uh they use it the
whole time and no more G for it we
checked in with Susan harb from Calgary
who is trying to keep her and her
children alive she sent us this text we
are almost Running Out of Water we
didn't shower for more than 10 days I
had to wipe the kids and myself with
wipes to maintain their
hygiene the trickle of trucks carrying
food water and medicine is a relief but
today the UN agency that distributes it
inside Gaza said it will have to Halt
its operations as of tomorrow night if
no fuel is also allowed in so far fuel
has not been allowed into the strip
without fuel the generators cannot
produce electricity for hospitals for
bakeries and for the water desalination
plants it is reported eight more Aid
trucks made it into Gaza today un
agencies are making increasingly
desperate pleas for unimpeded Access
today the US Secretary of State repeated
that Israel has the right to defend
itself but added that humanitarian
pauses in the air strikes must be
considered to protect civilians in Gaza
and the UN Secretary General said he is
concerned Israel's Siege on Gaza
violates International humanitarian law
Jackson prco reports on a fiery meeting
of the UN Security Council the situ
sitation in the Middle East is growing
more dire by the hour the conflict
spilled onto the floor of the UN
Security Council as the UN Secretary
General tried to walk a fine line it is
important to also recognize the attacks
by amas did not happen in a vacum
Israel's foreign minister was livid Mr
Secretary General in what war do you
live definitely this is not our word the
UN has called on Hamas to immediately
release its hostages and reaffirmed
Israel's right to security it also
accuses Israel of violating
International humanitarian law by
cutting off supplies to Gaza
AIG 3 years old displaying pictures of
the children still held captive Israel's
foreign minister argued no response to
Hamas could possibly be too heavy-handed
tell me what is a proportion response
for killing of babies diplomacy remains
deadlocked over calls for a ceasefire
that don't explicitly condemn Hamas more
Injustice and more killing will not make
Israel
safer no amount of weapons no Alliance
will bring to it
security only peace will the US fully
backs Israel but is increasingly calling
for restraint and the flow of Aid we
know Hamas does not represent the
Palestinian people and Palestinian
civilians are not to blame for the
Carnage committed by us Palestinian
civilians must be
protected the only Common Thread seems
to be fear of a wider Regional War
backed by Iran and its proxies the UN
warns civilians will pay the price for
whatever comes next Jackson crosco
Global News
Washington the man who decides what
comes next is Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu his government
released these photos of him today
visiting a special unit trained in the
demolition of tunnels he told them the
next stage is coming and they have one
mission to smash Hamas he has been
threatening to invade Gaza for the last
17 days at the same time under pressure
from families of the hostages to
negotiate their release first and aware
many in Israel blame him for the
security failures that allowed Hamas to
Stage its deadly attack Redmond Shannon
on what Israel's prime minister is
weighing lying in we wait 17 days after
the Hamas attack Israeli tanks still sit
at the border with
Gaza the Defense Forces said Tuesday
they're ready to go and awaiting the
instructions amid news reports of
tensions between the forces's leadership
and the government prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu had to issue a
statement assuring Israelis they're all
working
together if and when there is a ground
assault many families of hostages are
terrified of what it could mean for
their loved ones I don't know what is
the right way to do
it um I have to trust the Israeli
government there is time for for the
government for the military to have and
I hope so a more considerate approach
than probably and they enter into Gaza
the day two after Middle East analyst
Yosi meckelberg believes the emergency
War government including Centrist Benny
gance means Netanyahu doesn't need to
Pander to the far right the longtime
leader also faces International pressure
to hold back we heard from President
Biden yes we support you but don't
repeat the same mistake we did in 911
but a delayed ground Invasion doesn't
mean it's not going to happen it's not
process that happens overnight
particularly when you're are looking at
the nature of the challenge that is
awaiting reportedly uh in Gaza Street
this former Israeli intelligence
official believes that Hamas releasing
some hostages only gives false hope
Hamas hope that by doing that he will
first prevent an Israeli Massive Attack
ground operation Netanyahu was already
deeply unpopular before this
unprecedented crisis he knows a misstep
could seal his political fate Redman
Channon Global News
London the fate of the hostages held in
Gaza was addressed by a Hamas
spokesperson today gazi hammed a member
of the political Bureau of Hamas spoke
with our crystal ganing in Beirut
Crystal Don agazi ahed tells me that he
wants the International Community to
condemn Israel for the number of
civilians that have been killed in air
strikes a number that he this afternoon
pegged at
5,791 although he does say that number
is constantly changing because of the
number of air strikes on Gaza he also
says that he wants the internet interal
Community to push Israel to allow for
more Aid to enter Gaza as far as the
hostages he says that they are being
well cared for and in fact he wants to
see more be set free we succeeded to
make some steps and releas the first
women and her daughter and yesterday we
released also too and we are to deal as
I said positively with this point taking
the the women and the children and the
elderly was that a
mistake look uh
I think this is not what Our intention
it is not our intention to to care
civilians despite those claims more than
1,400 Israelis were killed in the
October 7th
attack G ommen says they want the
aggression to stop he says the air
strikes put hostages in Peril he wants
the International Community to push
Israel harder to permit more Aid
deliveries in order to save lives but
his biggest point is that the occupation
must end occupation is the source of all
evils and pain and instability we want
to stop this we want to stop this and I
think even the the forget Hamas the
president Abbas he spent 30 years in
negotiation with Israel and TS and
Accords and agreements but he got
nothing he got more settlements more uh
more killing hammed says though peace
and stability is desired they fight
against occupation will continue we have
the hope and the possibility that
someday we we defeat occupation gazi
Ahmed was measured in our interview in a
press conference he was a little more
defiant he called on people around the
world to continue to take to the streets
in support of Palestinians and he said
if Israel does enter Gaza with a ground
operation there will be a fight Donna
crystal ganing in Beirut thanks Crystal
a tragic case of intimate partner
violence coming up the shootings that
left five people including three
children
dead police in Northwestern Ontario are
investigating what they say is a case of
intimate partner violence the bodies of
five people including three children
were found after shootings at two homes
in Sous St Marie shalima Maharaj
explains what we know about the tragic
case the community is grieving and we're
in mourning over the loss senseless loss
really of uh multiple community members
and uh when you've got uh the loss of
children involved it makes it that much
more uh difficult to comprehend two
separate scenes cord off once we
understand uh how we got to where we got
to unfortunately last night we'll have
to see uh if there's anything that we
can do to avoid future events like this
from happening Sue St Marie police say
around 10:20 Monday night a call was
made to 911 about someone breaking into
a home when officers arrived they found
a 41-year-old dead from a gunshot wound
but the shooter was nowhere in sight 10
minutes later another call to 911 about
a person with a firearm at a home nearby
there police found a 45-year-old person
who had been shot and had to be rushed
to hospital inside the home officers
made a heartbreaking Discovery the
bodies of three children ages 6 7 and 12
all dead from gunshot wounds police say
it appears the 44-year-old shooter died
from a self-inflicted gunshot wound
police not disclosing the relationship
between any of the individuals involved
or their identities we're uh obviously
conducting a thorough uh criminal
investigation and uh as a result of that
we'll have to withhold that information
at this time police posting to social
media this tragedy was the result of
intimate partner violence in a statement
to Global News Algoma District school
board's director Director of Education
said the entire Community is heartbroken
and Mourns the loss of three students
overnight in Sue St Marie we need to
proactively take care of each other we
have to look at each other's lives
shalima Maharaj Global
News still ahead the largest First
Nation settlement agreement in Canadian
[Music]
history a federal court judge has
approved a $23 billion settlement for
hundreds of thousands of first nation's
children and their families it's
intended to address chronic underfunding
of unreserved child welfare services as
David Aken reports Advocates are pleased
but say the government still has a long
way to go David well Donna this is the
single largest settlement of its kind
$23 billion and it was really not a
matter of if the court would approve the
settlement but rather when the
settlement is the result of a complaint
first made in 2007 by the Assembly of
the First Nations and the first nation's
child and family caring Society the
Trudeau government first agreed to
settle when it took office in 2015 but
it took more than 7 years to sort out
what the government called a complex
claim funds will now flow to about
300,000 first nation's children or their
families this is a recognition of the
enormous harm caused uh through the
child welfare system and and I think
it's important that Canadians recognize
that this is an important step towards
reconciliation advocates for the health
of first nation's children say that harm
continues to be done that the federal
government continues to underfund the
first nation's Child Health and Welfare
system relative to the system for
non-indigenous children the problem has
not been fixed Advocate Cindy Blackstock
said in an email sent while she was on a
flight Tuesday in approving the
compensation deal the federal court made
clear that it is not releasing Canada
from any accountability for ongoing
discrimination and that too is a point
the government concedes as it promises
to work with indigenous Partners to
continue to improve Health and Welfare
Services for Canada's first nation's
children Donna David Aken in Ottawa
thanks
David the longest life next the story of
Bobby the world's oldest
[Music]
dog it's been said the only flaw of dogs
is that their lives are too short the
average lifespan is 10 to 13 years and
then there's Bobby the world's oldest
dog he was more than 31 years old when
he died in Portugal and all dog owners
want to know his secret here's Eric
senson walking the dog is well the first
step in a long happy canine life and
letting them run off the leash even
better says John Cooper watching his
Boston Terrier you see Lily over there
just living her best
life a good diet helps socializing with
other dogs makes a difference but what
could possibly explain
Bobby a Portuguese rafo a kind of mut
who lived to age 31 that's like a human
living to
140 he was never chained up a day in his
life said Bobby's owner Leonel Costa he
had freedom and our love throughout his
life the Guinness Book of Records
verified his birthday in 1992 and after
that Bobby roamed rural Portugal eating
Natural Foods like fresh fish so
fascinating that veterinarian Karen
Becker spent days studying Bobby she's
co-author of the forever dog it's a very
simple easy quiet beautiful calm
peaceful life was the first thing that
hit me seems like most dog owners have
the right instincts it's love exercise
nutritious food and they get to run
without me running all good things
though for Bobby maybe something more
says Dr Becker I believe all of those
variables and exceptional DNA was
probably the perfect recipe for why he
was a 31y old dog Becker has sent
Bobby's DNA for analysis by scientists
in Hungary to better understand that
while every dog has its day Bobby had
11,487 of them Eric soron Global News
Toronto a Bobby and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Freez and you know how sometimes you
feel older than you are or maybe it's
just me anyway there is some news about
the moon there is evidence it is 40
million years older than scientists
thought they discovered this through
fresh analysis of a lunar rock that was
brought back on the Apollo 17 mission in
1972 the last time humans set foot on
the moon scientists say when you know
how old something is you can better
understand what has happened to it in
its history I feel you moon thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
byebye
[Music]